en esta ocasión tenemos aquí a dos
vectores el vector am que es este que
estoy representando de color azul el
cual tiene una magnitud de 3 y además
tiene un ángulo de 30 grados con
respecto a la horizontal o podríamos
decir con respecto al eje de las x al
eje positivo de las equis que bueno no
he dibujado aquí pero vamos a hablar
también de este otro vector el vector b
el cual tiene una magnitud de 2 es decir
la longitud de este vector es 2 y además
tiene una dirección de 135 grados con
respecto al eje horizontal al eje
positivo de las equis y bueno lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo y tal vez en
el siguiente es pensar cuál va a ser la
magnitud y la dirección de la suma de
estos dos vectores es decir yo lo que
quiero saber es cuál va a ser la
magnitud y la dirección de la suma de
este vector a ok este que tenemos aquí
este vector ve a esto le voy a sumar
este vector b y yo lo que quiero saber
es qué es lo que va a pasar con la suma
de estos dos vectores ahora lo que
quiero que hagas en este vídeo es que lo
intente resolver por ti mismo y para eso
sería muy bueno que pausar el vídeo e
intentes llegar a una respuesta
bueno una forma de obtener esto es
primero descomponiendo cada uno de los
vectores en sus componentes verticales y
horizontales así como por ejemplo este
vector am lo podemos descomponer
y déjame tomar un nuevo color y lo
podemos descomponer en un vector
horizontal este vector horizontal que
estoy dibujando justo aquí ok a este
vector a lo podemos ver como la suma de
este vector la suma de este vector
horizontal más
adam pues un nuevo vector y déjame tomar
este color más otro vector vertical más
este vector vertical que estoy dibujando
justo aquí ok si nosotros nos tomamos la
suma de este vector horizontal más este
vector vertical entonces vamos a obtener
el vector am y bueno esto no es otra
cosa más que una versión escalada del
vector unitario y a mí déjame ponerlo
así si tenemos por ejemplo por aquí y
déjame ver que este sea mi vector
unitario aquí tengo uno
23 ok entonces más o menos director y se
vería así mi vector y es el vector
unitario en la dirección horizontal este
de aquí vamos a ponerle que es mi vector
y ok el vector un interior y entonces si
te das cuenta éste es algo por este
vector y es una cantidad por este vector
unitario y es decir una versión escalada
de este vector unitario y y si nosotros
y déjame ponerlo con un color más
llamativo si nosotros agarramos por
ejemplo a éste
a ésta como una versión escalada de este
vector j es decir de la versión vertical
del vector unitario y déjame dibujarlo
por aquí por aquí tendríamos más o menos
algo así
este sería mi vector unitario vertical
ok
así que lo voy a poner aquí el vector
unitario j si te das cuenta aquí tengo
algo algo que multiplica a este vector
unitario j
es decir podemos descomponer a este
vector
como la suma de dos vectores algo por el
vector horizontal unitario y le voy a
agregar algo por el vector vertical
unitario j
es decir estoy descomponiendo a este
vector a y si te das cuenta pasa lo
mismo para ver si nosotros nos tomamos a
d
no podemos descomponer en un vector
unitario en algo por un vector unitario
horizontal algo más o menos así ok y
déjame poner algo así ok de lujo y bueno
también tenemos algo que multiplica al
vector unitario vertical y bueno se
vería algo más o menos así más o menos
así ok entonces si te das cuenta para el
vector de pasa es lo mismo lo podemos
descomponer en algo por el vector
unitario y más algo por el vector
unitario j y bueno lo que sería muy
bueno saber es por cuánto tenemos que
escalar cada uno de estos vectores
unitarios así que vamos a hacerlo lo
primero que te puedes dar cuenta
este vector am es que tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo y además es un
triángulo rectángulo de la forma 30
grados centãgrados este de aquí vale 60
grados 90 grados y los triángulos 30 60
90 cumplen la propiedad de que este lado
mide la mitad de lo que mide la
hipotenusa por lo tanto si la hipotenusa
vale 3 este lado mide 3 entre 23 medios
la mitad de este lado ok
mientras que este otro lado de aquí
bueno este lado de aquí ni de la raíz de
3 y lo multiplicamos por el lado pequeño
es decir me quedaría tres veces la raíz
de 3 entre 2 lo voy a por así tres veces
la raíz de 3
ok todo esto entre dos de lujo ya sé
cuánto vale cada uno de los lados ahora
hay otra forma de verlo si no recuerdas
qué es lo que pasa cuando los triángulos
30 60 90 entonces quiero que te des
cuenta que tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo y como tenemos este triángulo
rectángulo
y aquí tenemos un ángulo de 30 grados y
entonces podríamos decir que este lado
este lado el opuesto entre la hipotenusa
que vale 3 es lo mismo que el seno de
este ángulo es fácil hay que recordar
solamente el soca tohá lo voy a poner
aquí son cada hoja y por lo tanto ya con
esto podemos decir que el seno de 30
grados y es máster que al cruzarlo por
aquí el seno el seno de 30 grados esto
es exactamente lo mismo que el lado
opuesto a 30 grados el lado opuesto a 30
grados dividido entre lo que vale la
hipotenusa la longitud de la hipotenusa
que es 3 esto entre 3 y bueno de aquí
podemos obtener que entonces el lado
opuesto que es lo que nosotros estamos
buscando el lado opuesto lo podemos
obtener como tres veces que multiplica
el seno de 30 lo voy a poner así tres
veces que multiplica
seno el seno de 30 grados ok
y bueno si nosotros hacemos esto en la
calculadora te vas a dar cuenta que el
seno de 30 grados esto es lo mismo que
un medio que un médium y por lo tanto me
quedaría tres por un medio 10 por eso
que llegamos a tres medios y pasa algo
muy parecido con este lado de aquí si
nosotros nos fijamos que este es el lado
adyacente entonces ahora vamos a buscar
a el coseno de este ángulo de 30 grados
y déjame ponerlo aquí el coseno de este
ángulo de 30 grados esto es exactamente
lo mismo que el lado adyacente ok
entre esto dividido entre la longitud de
la hipotenusa que es 3 y de aquí
entonces podemos decir que vamos a
obtener el adyacente de la siguiente
manera el lado adyacente es exactamente
lo mismo que esto lo voy a pasar
multiplicando multiplico todo por 3 y me
queda tres veces el coseno el seno de 30
y bueno si tú haces en tu calculadora el
po seno de 30 grados te vas a dar cuenta
que esto es lo mismo que raíz de 3 raíz
de 3 sobre 2 y por eso llegamos a esta
expresión de aquí tres veces la raíz de
tres sobre dos y si te das cuenta es
exactamente lo mismo que encontramos
aquí arriba y es más si no me crees
podríamos corroborarlo déjame traer por
acá la calculadora y vamos a ver que me
sale cuando yo me tomo el seno de 30
grados a 30 le voy a sacar el seno es
0.5 ok justo este resultado que tenemos
aquí y si tú quieres ver cuánto es el
coseno de 30 grados veamos 30 grados le
voy a sacar el cose no es esta cantidad
de aquí y bueno esto es lo mismo que la
raíz de 3 sobre 2 lo podemos ver 3 si yo
le sacó raíz ya esto lo divido entre 2 a
darte cuenta que llegamos al mismo
resultado y por lo tanto estamos
verificando que en efecto esto es cierto
por lo tanto voy a quitar la calculadora
y vamos a seguir trabajando con esto que
tenemos aquí
pero ahora pensemos qué es lo que pasa
con este triángulo que tenemos aquí y si
te das cuenta lo primero que me vas a
decir es cuánto valen los ángulos y
bueno este ángulo de aquí es
suplementario a este ángulo de 135
grados por lo tanto este ángulo es de 45
grados lo voy a poner aquí 45 grados ok
entonces este es mi ángulo recto y por
lo tanto es de aquí también va a ser un
ángulo de 45 grados de 45 grados estamos
hablando de un triángulo 45 grados 90
grados 45 grados ok y de la misma forma
que nosotros tenemos aquí abajo para
encontrar este lado que es el lado
adyacente a este ángulo de 45 grados
bueno pues lo vamos a encontrar
multiplicando la hipotenusa 2 la
hipotenusa vale 2 que multiplica a su
vez al coseno
'la coseno de 45 grados de 45 grados el
soca tohá y bueno este lado este lado
que sería en mi lado opuesto éste lo
sacó con
la medida de la hipotenusa que en este
caso es 2 la hipotenusa que vale 2 ok y
ya esto multiplicarlo por el seno el
seno de 45 grados de 45 grados ok el
lado adyacente siempre lo encontramos
multiplicando a la hipotenusa por el
coseno del ángulo que se forme en este
caso es 30 grados y en este caso 45
grados mientras que el lado opuesto lo
vamos a encontrar multiplicando la
longitud de la hipotenusa por el seno
del ángulo que se formen ok y bueno si
tú agarras tu calculadora y metes seno
de 45 grados te vas a dar cuenta que vas
a encontrar un número con muchos
decimales pero si nosotros recordamos
los triángulos 45 grados 90 grados 45
grados bueno pues este es en 945 vale lo
mismo que la raíz de 2 entre 2 así que
lo voy a poner aquí la raíz de 2 entre 2
esto es lo mismo que el seno de 45
grados ok y si tú metes en tu
calculadora y de igual manera quieres
encontrar
seno de 45 grados bueno pues te vas a
dar cuenta que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que raíz de dos raíz de dos sobre
dos también ok y por lo tanto ya tengo
el seno de 45 grados el corte de 45
grados y habrá que multiplicarlo por 2
para encontrar estos lados así que vamos
a hacerlo si yo multiplico 2 por raíz de
2 entre 2
bueno pues de todo esto me va a quedar
solamente que este lado vale a raíz de 2
ok porque este 2 con este 2 se van ok y
solamente me va a quedar raíz de 2 por
este vector unitario y ok y después de
este lado va a pasar algo muy parecido
si nosotros multiplicamos 2 por raíz de
2 entre 2 bueno pues este lado de aquí
han dejado en ponerlo así este lado de
aquí es lo mismo que raíz de dos que
multiplica al vector unitario jota y por
lo tanto esto nos va a dar pie a que ya
podemos escribir nuestro vector a en
nuestro vector ven como la suma de estas
dos componentes una componente
horizontal y una componente vertical
así que vamos a hacerlo y para eso
déjenme bajar un poco esta pantalla voy
a bajar un poco la pantalla a algo más o
menos así ok y vamos a escribir aquí
cuánto vale ahí cuánto vale ve el vector
a el vector am lo voy a poner con este
color al vector
lo podemos descomponer en dos
componentes una componente horizontal
que es esta de aquí entonces la voy a
escribir al vector am lo podemos ver
como tres veces la raíz de tres entre
dos por el vector unitario y estamos
escalando el vector unitario y y
entonces si lo multiplicamos por tres
veces la raíz de tres entre dos
encaminamos esta distancia entonces
debemos ponerlo tres veces la raíz de
tres ok esto dividido entre dos
multiplicado por el vector unitario y ok
ya esto le estamos sumando déjame
ponerlo así a esto le vamos a sumar
bueno la otra componente la componente
vertical y esta componente vertical es
escalar este
unitario j multiplicando por este número
de aquí por tres medios entonces si a
esto le sumamos tres medios del vector
unitario jota el vector unitario
vertical y está de lujo porque ya con
esto tenemos una nueva forma de
representar a este vector y si yo me
tomo este vector ya este vector le sumo
este otro vector entonces llegó a mi
vector y por lo tanto puedo ver al
vector am como tres veces la raíz de
tres sobre dos por el vector unitario y
que es el vector que se mueve de manera
horizontal más tres medios el vector
unitario jota que es el que se mueve de
forma vertical y bueno de manera similar
para el vector b y lo voy a poner aquí
mi vector b entonces lo voy a
descomponer ahora en sus dos componentes
en su componente horizontal y bueno su
componente horizontal es raíz de dos a
pero negativo porque recuerda que en
nuestro vector y apunta hacia
este lado hacia acá apunta nuestro
vector unitario y raíz de 2 x y se vería
más o menos así se vería un vector que
va hasta acá y como estamos del otro
lado entonces tenemos que tomar la
versión negativa de este vector unitario
y entonces este vector b lo podemos
escribir como déjeme poner esto así lo
podemos escribir como a menos la raíz de
2 menos
la raíz de 2 ok por este vector unitario
y por este vector unitario y ahora
estamos yendo hacia la izquierda y
después tenemos este vector unitario
jota entonces a esto le voy a sumar la
componente vertical y la componente
vertical es raíz de 2 raíz de 2 que
multiplica a este vector unitario
vertical j ok justo esto y una vez que
ya tenemos separados en su componente
vertical y en su componente horizontal
ahora creo que ya podemos pensar en
cuánto va aa
en la suma del vector a con el vector b
y para eso déjenme bajar un poco más la
pantalla porque ahora vamos a pensar en
cómo podemos representar a la suma y
déjeme tomar este color de aquí la suma
de este vector a ok con este vector b
a esto le voy a sumar le voy a sumar
este otro vector b le voy a sumar este
vector ven ok y si nosotros nos fijamos
en la suma de estos dos vectores bueno
pues esto va a ser exactamente igual a
tomarme la suma de estas dos componentes
más estas dos componentes y es más
déjame atraparlas para pegarlas aquí voy
a copiar esta parte de aquí le voy a
pegar ok entonces esto lo voy a poner
justo por aquí ok ya esto le voy a sumar
esta parte de aquí que es mi vector me
por lo tanto también voy a tomar esta
parte de aquí ok la voy a atrapar la voy
a pegar ok y ya la tengo justo x
es decir que si yo me tomo la suma de
este vector con este vector es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme estas
dos componentes y a estas dos
componentes sumarle estas otras dos
componentes y bueno si te das cuenta
esto lo podemos reorganizar de una
manera distinta podemos juntar lo que
tenga que ver con la componente
horizontal y lo que tenga que ver con la
componente vertical así que déjeme bajar
un poco más la pantalla y ahora vamos a
pensar qué es lo que nos sale de
tomarnos a esta suma de aquí
si yo atrapo esta suma de aquí ok y la
copio y después la pego ok entonces esta
suma va a ser exactamente lo mismo
ok antes me ponerla por acá que tomarme
esta primera parte que tenemos aquí que
tiene que ver con el vector unitario y
ya esto sumarle esta otra parte que
también tiene que ver con el vector
unitario y y por lo tanto esto lo
podemos escribir como tres veces la raíz
3 ok esto dividido entre 2 - menos la
raíz de 2 ok esto todo esto que
multiplica a este vector unitario y que
multiplica a este vector unitario y ya
esto habrá que sumarle am y déjeme abre
paréntesis
tres medios tres medios más la raíz de
dos más la raíz de dos ok
todo esto que multiplica a este vector
unitario jota y ya está aquí tenemos una
representación de esta suma que nosotros
queríamos es esta parte de aquí que tal
vez se vea un poco complicada pero no te
preocupes esto lo podemos poner en la
calculadora y obtener una buena
aproximación pero lo que quiero que veas
es que ya tenemos
esta suma que nosotros queríamos
descompuesta en sus dos componentes en
su componente horizontal y en su
componente vertical lo que quiero ver en
el siguiente vídeo es una vez que ya
obtuvimos esto de aquí y obtuvimos esta
suma separada en sus dos componentes voy
a tratar de obtenerla
y la dirección de este vector que me
resulte de la suma del vector am con el
vector